[Música]
el presidente Alberto Fernández dio un
paso al costado en la carrera por la
presidencia de Argentina al anunciar que
no buscará un segundo mandato el próximo
22 de octubre cuando se celebra en
elecciones generales la decisión de
Fernández que se da en medio de una baja
popularidad y una crisis económica cada
vez más profunda sacude el panorama
electoral Además de que la obra
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández está
inhabilitada para ejercer cargos
públicos tras ser condenada por cargos
de corrupción entonces la pregunta que
queda ahora es quién tomará las banderas
del peronismo para el análisis saludamos
en Bogotá a Nicolás el liendo consultor
y analista político argentino Nicolás
gracias y buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela y un saludo para toda
la audiencia también comienzo
preguntándole cómo cambia en el panorama
electoral el hecho de que ahora Alberto
Fernández sale del juego político
bueno en principio esta era una decisión
que se esperaba dado los altos niveles
de impopularidad que tiene Alberto
Fernández que rozan entre el 78 80 por
ciento dependiendo de las encuestas
como tú bien decías también hay una mega
crisis económica que en la última semana
se aceleró y que ha llevado a poner en
riesgo digamos una victoria del
oficialismo en las próximas elecciones
de octubre de 2019 de 2023 entonces la
salida de Alberto Fernández viene a
descomprimir la atención que hay dentro
del gobierno de la coalición de gobierno
y un tercer elemento es que hace mucho
tiempo las relaciones con la
vicepresidenta y líder del movimiento
Cristina Fernández estaban rotas por lo
tanto ante la inviabilidad de su
candidatura era solo cuestión de días
para que Alberto Fernández diera un paso
al costado y ahora se abre una enorme
cantidad de escenarios respecto a qué
hará el oficialismo Y quién será el
candidato en las próximas elecciones
Bueno hablemos sobre Cristina porque hay
especulaciones sobre si volverá a ser
candidata pero los ojos también están
puestos por ejemplo en el actual
ministro de economía Sergio masa que es
otro de los líderes de la coalición
quien debe tomar entonces las banderas
del peronismo Usted qué opina
bueno en principio hay un grupo dentro
del del peronismo que está buscando que
el operativo clamor No es cierto que
Cristina Tomen las banderas y sea como
líder natural del movimiento la
candidata en las próximas elecciones el
problema allí y Cristina esto lo lo
tiene dentro de su consideración y su
alto nivel de imagen negativa que tiene
luego de dos a dos periodos
presidenciales de gestión y este periodo
como vicepresidenta que llegan al 70 por
ciento entonces ante la inviabilidad
también de esa candidatura por lo menos
en principio a partir de las encuestas
de imagen negativa y los problemas
judiciales que posee en caso de perder
Se podrían agudizar Cristina podría
estar buscando nuevamente como ocurrió
con la candidatura Alberto Fernández un
un tercer Aliado no un una pata distinta
dentro del peronismo que podría ser
Sergio más al actual ministro de
economía y que los próximos semanas
meses que le quedan al gobierno tendrá
una prueba de fuego para descomprimir la
situación bajar la inflación
controlar la devaluación muy fuerte que
existe en el país y con eso hacer viable
su candidatura como cierta estabilidad
que traería el juego sin embargo hay
otros actores en caso de que la
candidatura de masa no funcione que
también están empujando pero tienen
menor relevancia impacto en principio
que la figura de masa o de Cristina
Fernández Como podrían ser Daniel sioli
que ya fue candidato en 2019 y fue
gobernador dos veces de Buenos Aires y
otros ministros que ha tenido los
distintas gestiones kineristas en los
últimos 20 años Bueno pero entre tanto
se acercan las elecciones primarias en
agosto y en este abanico de
posibilidades hay un debate sobre qué
será más conveniente para el oficialismo
si llegar a las primarias a ofrecer
candidatos o tener ya un aspirante de
definido usted que cree que va a pasar
bueno en general el pamperonismo que
está dentro de una coalición que se
llama el frente de todos ha ido siempre
con un candidato definido a las a las
primarias abiertas simultáneas
obligatorias las paso que se celebrarán
el 13 de agosto para eso tienen previsto
realizar un congreso partidario el 16 de
mayo lo anunciaron ayer en donde
definirán las candidaturas irán con
lista única o con listas separadas por
un lado están quienes prefieren ir con
lista de unidad como Cristina Fernández
y cerella en principio quien con su dedo
Determine Quién será el candidato si no
es ella por otro lado dentro de los que
apoyaban Alberto Fernández al presidente
actual prefieren que haya competencia
dentro de el movimiento para ver quién
es el sucesor entonces esa es la puja
inicial pero en términos históricos y
tradicionales el movimiento casi siempre
ha elegido un solo candidato una lista
de unidad para ir a las primarias bueno
y entre tanto mientras está
el lado del gobierno tomando decisiones
respecto a sus candidatos usted como ve
a la oposición en términos de estructura
de liderazgo de apoyo popular para estas
elecciones
la oposición parte con con una cierta
ventaja a partir de el contexto
económico y político regional y nacional
no O sea hay una enorme incertidumbre y
una altísima volatilidad Eso hace que no
sepamos Bien dentro de cada movimiento
Quiénes son los candidatos
Mauricio macri ya anunció también su
renunciamiento entonces vale decir que
tenemos tres presidentes que no serán
candidatos un escenario único en la
Argentina en los cuarenta años de
democracia
y por el lado entonces de Juntos por el
cambio allí hay un escenario donde está
Patricia bullrich una persona más
considerada de la línea dura de la de la
derecha y por otro lado Horacio
Rodríguez larreta el alcalde de la de la
ciudad de Buenos Aires quienes
identificado con una línea más moderada
la puja está muy pareja entre ambos y
por la extrema derecha colando un nuevo
candidato que es Javier milei que es la
sensación digamos política de de
Argentina que ha venido creciendo en
todas las encuestas y ha sido capaz de
capitalizar el descontento ciudadano
hacia la falta de efectividad del
gobierno actual el legado anterior o las
incertidumbres y peleas dentro de Juntos
por el cambio y la gente que busca
soluciones efectivistas y rápidas como
las que propone mi ley Entonces el
escenario es de tríos No es cierto o sea
un 30% en la intención de votos
aproximada entre 30 y 25 estaría en el
oficialismo hoy por hoy en las encuestas
un treinta veinticinco también en junto
por el cambio y un poco menos pero
creciendo permanentemente esta
candidatura de mi ley como candidato de
extrema derecha Bueno ahora lo que
tendríamos que preguntarnos es si la
oposición va a lograr capitalizar esa
división o esa esa postura indefinida
que existe ahora mismo dentro del
peronismo Yo le agradezco mucho ese
Nicolás liendo consultora y analista
político argentino que tenga un buen día
Muchas gracias Ángeles y saludos a todos
a nuestros televidentes sigan con
nosotros en directo a América ya
volvemos con más después de una pequeña
pausa
[Música]